bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de
vous retrouver dans ça vous regarde on
direct au sommaire ce soir demandez le
programme d' emmanuel macron le
président candidat vient de dévoiler son
projet de campagne devant un parterre de
plus de 200 journalistes à aubervilliers
nous y serons éducation travail santé
beaucoup de mesures dans la continuité
de son action et quelques propositions
chocs voire même clivante notamment
concernant les enseignants vont débattre
avec les représentants des différents
candidats sur ce plateau dans un instant
notre grand témoin ce soir est un grand
humanitaire médecins de guerre il a
passé plusieurs séjours en syrie pour
lui la stratégie de vladimir poutine
bombarder les civils les terroriser en
frappant les hôpitaux ou encore un
théâtre aujourd'hui à marioupol est tout
sauf une surprise il alerte aussi sur
les réfugiés attention aux couloirs
humanitaires il pourrait servir d'armes
de guerre enfin une pythie est avec nous
ce soir enfin ce sera la page
présidentielle à 24 jours du premier
tour dans le scan ce soir stéphane
blakowski à regarder marine le pen face
à baba benjamin grange a observé lui les
réseaux sociaux la campagne est bien les
bains lancée et richard vers lui lui
dira pourquoi les écolos ne décolle pas
alors qu'il devrait avoir un boulevard
devant la porte minutes sévère partie
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs
3h30 de présentation et de questions
réponses face à plus de 100 journalistes
le président candidat a fini par dégager
du temps pour présenter son programme
éducation travail santé une impression
de grand inventaire de mesures alors
parfois techniques mais dont quelques
unes vise à renverser la table avec une
ligne directrice le donnant-donnant où
le principe est bien que les droits ne
vont pas sans les devoirs on va en
parler ce soir avec vous car le lis
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes le maire de poissy proche des
manuels macron vous est même l'un de ses
amis vous de vous le rappeler
régulièrement c'est dans votre ville que
s'est tenu le premier débat du candidat
macron avec avec des habitants de chez
vous on s'en souvient bonsoir sina
thabet soir bienvenue sur ce plateau
candidate les républicains en
seine-saint-denis aux élections
législatives et donc forcément soutien
de valérie pécresse bonsoir stanislas
rigaud porte parole du parti et
reconquête le parti d'eric zemmour enfin
bon soir thomas porte bienvenue vous
êtes membre de l'union populaire de jean
luc mélenchon je vous donne la parole
nova tout de suite pour commencer cette
émission rejoindre les docks
d'aubervilliers où nous attend et des
mondains gava bonsoir elsa vous avez
donc assister à ces que longue très
longue conférence de presse du président
quand idar que faut-il d'abord on
retenir sur le fond quelles sont les
propositions les plus fortes les plus
innovantes
il a écouté myriam le président candidat
a développé son programme autour de
trois axes une nation plus indépendante
une société plus unies un état au
service de la nation alors sur les
mesures il n'y a pas eu de grande
surprise puisqu'elle était déjà plus ou
moins évoqué retraite à 65 ans emmanuel
macron en avait déjà parlé une
convention citoyenne prévue sur la fin
de vie ça aussi c'était un petit peu
dans l'air et puis c'est peut-être sur
les colts emmanuel macron a voulu être
le plus disruptif s'il est élu il promet
une grande concertation plus d'autonomie
pour les directeurs d'établissement
hausse de la rémunération des
enseignants oui mais avec des conditions
d nous elle mission notamment ça fera
parler dans le monde enseignant très
certainement et puis la confort confirmé
vouloir réformer le rsa avec en
contrepartie de cette allocation case 15
à 20 heures de formation ou de travail
un programme qui semble pencher un peu à
droite si bien pendant que cette
conférence de presse et bien les
soutiens de valérie pécresse y ont vu
une photocopie du programme de leur
candidate ils ont twitté en ce sens
pendant la conférence de presse des
manuels macron alors emmanuel macron de
2022 est il plus à droite que celui 2017
et bien la question de lui a été posée
écoutez ce qu'il répond
j'assume sur ce sujet pour toutes celles
et ceux qui en convoque les manuels et
l'art des traces et gaullistes
le général disait lui même la france est
de gauche quand elle est pour le
mouvement le changement et elle a besoin
aussi de décisions de droite quand il
faut leur ordre le travail le mérite
dans le programme que je viens de vous
dire la volonté que je vient d'exprimer
il y a un manque ablement des réformes
des ambitions que vous pourriez
qualifier comme venant et autant de
l'inspiration de gauche d'autres
d'inspiration de droite je les assume
totalement parce que je pense que
fondamentalement c'est ce pourquoi les
françaises et les français mais avait
choisi il ya cinq ans alors voilà pour
le fond sur la forme est là est ce que
le candidat retrouvé les accents de 2017
alors évidemment myriam il est pas du
tout dans la même position puisqu'il est
le président sortant cette conférence de
presse c'est aussi un peu un bilan il
commençait beaucoup de phrases par
beaucoup a déjà été fait manière de dire
que le second quinquennat serait dans la
continuité
sur la forme on nous avait promis une
conférence de presse de 3 à 4 heures et
bien on nous avait pas menti un prêt de
quatre heures il faut dire qu'il y avait
plus de 200 journalistes dans la salle
alors emmanuel macron a tout d'abord
exposé son projet on nous avait promis
45 minutes c'est finalement une heure
trente pour détailler toutes ces mesures
et puis il a répondu à des dizaines de
questions de bonne volonté de bon coeur
même à la fin on voyait qu'il n'aurait
pas été contre en reprendre deux ou
trois mais c'est son équipe qui lui a
fait comprendre qu'il était temps
d'arrêter on a eu l'impression que
finalement c'était une démonstration une
réponse aux polémiques sur le fait qu il
esquivé le débat qu'il ne faisait pas
vraiment campagne il a répondu à
beaucoup beaucoup de questions des
journalistes alors pour préciser les
analyse ne peuvent pas le relancer le
titiller comme il le voudrait peut-être
il a assumé de ne pas vouloir débattre
avec les 11 autres candidats puisque
aucun autre président de sortant l'a
fait et puis il a également répondu au
président du sénat gérard larcher qui de
cette semaine dans le figaro et bien
remettez sa légitimité en cause s'il
était réélu sans faire campagne
ecoutez-le emmanuel macron
d'écouter
un président du sénat ne devrais pas
dire ça
en toute sincérité
quiconque est censé porter le suffrage
universel et dont la légitimité procède
des élus ne devraient pas s'amuser à
remettre en cause la limite et de la
légitimité de quelques élus que ce soit
y compris
ce sont des gens qui lui plaisent pas
une bonne idée
voilà donc quatre heures d'exercices
pour emmanuel macron devant les
journalistes demain il sera en
déplacement à pau encore devant des
journalistes et des français cette
fois-ci façon de dire qu'il va bien dans
l'arène merci merci beaucoup l amont à
gamma pour ce pour ce point complet car
le livre ont évidemment parler du fond
va rentrer dans le détail notamment sur
les questions liées à l'éducation parce
que voilà il propose des choses qui qui
risque de faire vraiment réagir
notamment le corps enseignant un mot sur
la manière dont emmanuel macron exécute
d'ailleurs en direct hurard larcher
franchement il n'est pas légitime à dire
ce qu'il a dit dans le figaro un une
campagne sans confrontation 100 sans
débat qui risque de peser oui il faut
voir si on est légitime quand même un
peu de mémoire j'en sais quelque chose
puisque je me suis présenté aux
élections municipales aux élections
départementales et on a vu ce qui s'est
passé derrière aux régionales c'est
comme dans le sport la météo est la même
pour tout le monde et de dire
aujourd'hui qu'un candidat serait
illégitime parce qu'il aurait enjambé
une élection ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que sous prétexte qu'il ya de
l'abstention alors le candidat n'est pas
légitime ce que je constate c'est que
risque d'abstention est bien sûr et puis
tout le monde est concerné ce que le
présent tout le monde est concerné
comme l'ensemble des comme l'ensemble
des présidents 8h24 jour pas plus tard
pas plus tard que monsieur mitterrand
pas plus tard que monsieur chirac en son
temps mais on sent vraiment énervé dans
la majorité cantons les le figaro ce
matin sur les propos de l'archer on les
propos factieux on est ridicule
franchement et deuxième personnage de
l'état monsieur leurs cieux de dire
qu'il engendre monsieur larcher c'est le
deuxième personnage de l'état ce que je
constate c'est c'est un exercice inédit
moi je suis rageant suis ravi évidemment
parce que c'est un exercice un peu salée
grand débat juste et comme je présentais
la séquence de poissy bah c'est un débat
qui a été qui a été ajustée et moi je
suis ravi qu'on est à la journée les
journalistes évidemment aujourd'hui
victoire
évitera la
nature je suis peut-être juste peut-être
de dire que vous aurez remarqué quand
même qu'à aucun moment le président
macron ne cite un seul nommément de ces
deux des autres des autres candidats
c'est peut-être ce qui fait la
différence avec un un certain nombre
d'entre eux quand on passe son temps à
taper comme des sourds matin midi et
soir bah ça fait juste une chose ça fait
monter le candidat qui est en face et
c'est le cas pour emmanuel macron je
vais certainement pas ces bouchées du
tout la même déception des terrains
démocratique mais mais mais c'est pas
grave monsieur gérard larcher et
président du sénat ils ont complètement
dans son dans son droit et dans son rôle
de rappeler qu'on a une démocratie et
qu'elle doit vivre et qu'elle doit
particulièrement vivre entendent entend
de présidentielle aujourd'hui je vous
êtes d'accord avec lui et a parlé d'une
élection aux jambes et à bas tout à fait
et de dire qu'on parle d'une élection en
jambes et ce n'est pas seulement parler
du taux d'abstention auxquels on fait
face qui franchement risquent d'être
énormes en cette éviction effectivement
le sent sur le terrain moi je le sens
quand je parle avec les dionysiens avec
les habitants de pierrefitte de
villetaneuse ils ne savent plus trop
quoi voter il était en attente d'une
prise de parole du candidat qui arrive
extrêmement tard ils ont l'impression de
se faire voler cette élection alors
séoudite par le tard mais il a parlé on
va venir sur le fond et il a parlé mais
csa intervient très très tard pour
permettre aux gens de faire un choix en
toute conscience de l'avenir de la
france john stockton années de ce pays
on est là justement pour débattre de ses
propositions première proposition choc
on y va sur l'éducation il propose un
pacte aux enseignants une augmentation
de salaire à la carte en fonction de
leur volonté ou non d'accepter de
nouvelles missions écouter le chef de
l'état candidat la revalorisation
nationales uniformes
compte tenu de la masse salariale n'est
pas la mesure la plus efficace et donc
ce que j'ai
et c'est de dire on propose un pacte aux
enseignants qui sont en place et leur
disent que vous êtes prêts à changer
votre manière de faire c'est à dire on
vous demande de nouvelles missions on
est prêt à les payer beaucoup mieux à
les reconnaître mieux par contre mon
souhait c'est que toutes les nouvelles
embauches se fasse sur la base de ce
nouveau contrat voilà un nouveau contrat
va y avoir du changement si les s'il est
réélu emmanuel macron thomas porte on
décide c'est une forme de
donnant-donnant travailler plus pour
gagner plus dans l'éducation nationale
comme le donnant-donnant d'emmanuel
macron il est toujours la destination ni
même public et parce qu'on pourra
évoquer tout à l'heure les aides qui
sont versées aux entreprises où on n'a
jamais demandé de contrepartie et lang
lang des enseignants mais je vais vous
le dire c'est une remise en cause de la
fonction publique et du statut
d'enseignant qui est aujourd'hui mis sur
la table par le président de la
république qui veut mettre en
concurrence à la fois les établissements
est à la fois les enseignants mais en
même temps c'est la poursuite du modèle
néolibéral de l'école qui est porté par
jean michel blanc coeur qu'il avait déjà
développé dans un livre avant d'être
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
vous ça fait déjà réagir qu'est-ce qui
vous
colle à deux vitesses qui peut croire
qu'on a le luxe de choisir dans quel
établissement mais son gamin quand on
est un quartier populaire quand on est
dans ie dans un milieu qui est plus
bourgeois entre guillemets on voit qu'il
va y avoir une école à deux vitesses est
malheureusement déjà le cas et
aujourd'hui on va voir des parents qui
vont choisir l'établissement en fonction
des classements qui vont dans les
journaux et ça c'est absolument pas
acceptable mais moi je veux juste dire
une chose sur le travailler plus on a
quand même des enseignants du premier
degré qui travaillent déjà 44 heures par
semaine secondaire
pour augmenter la charge de travail de
ces enseignants là je tente juste sur
une chose le bilan des moniales macron
dans l'éducation nationale on sait ce
que c'est ces sept mille neuf cent
postes supprimés en cinq ans c'est
l'équivalent de 175 collège voilà le
bilan des manuels macron karl olive
là-dessus système à deux vitesses école
à la carte injustice moi je prends le
pardon cher monsieur je prends le contre
exemple de ce que je connais très bien à
poissy en quartiers populaires donc on
est vraiment au coeur des quartiers en
politique de la ville où on a 20 % de
résultats supplémentaires tout
simplement parce que on a ouvert des
passerelles à la volonté de là de la
principale et de sons de son principal
adjoint ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
et ça dépend de la territorialisation et
la volonté celle au traitement
l'autonomie de recrutement et marseille
et entre
l'autonomie madame de ce qui se passe
aussi sur l'instruction civique
typiquement là on a du sport au coeur de
l'instruction civique et on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya moins d'absentéisme il ya 20%
de résultats supplémentaires par rapport
aux moyennes tout ce qu'on appelle en
réseau d'éducation prioritaire tu donc
ça fonctionne l'idée en gros de dire aux
enseignants rester plus longtemps après
la classe pour les devoirs remplacer des
professeurs absents et vous serez
augmenté c'est un peu ça ce pacte on n'a
pas encore les détails d'ailleurs on a
besoin d'avoir si vous en avez discuté
avec le chef de l'état comment ça va
fonctionner le constat qu'on peut ici
certainement former ensemble c'est que
les salaires des enseignants français
sont inférieurs en début de carrière de
près de 7% par rapport à la moyenne de
deûle ocde que tu demandé que propose le
candidat emmanuel macron c'est que
effectivement on est dans un contrat
gagnant gagnant typiquement le
périscolaire chez moi aujourd'hui est
effectué par des par des agents des
animateurs extérieur à l'éducation
nationale demain l'aide aux devoirs
demain le cam à pardonner c'est la fin
du statut de l'enseignant dans la
fonction publique non non pas du tout je
sais simplement on a un dégel
typiquement qui a été décidé par à
médine montchanin le dégel du ghana du
point c'est pour tous les fonctionnaires
donc y compris pour pour les enseignants
mais demain si on a des missions qui
sont nouvelles et qui sont payés de
façon supplémentaire dont combien laisse
quand même par exemple d'imaginer un
directeur de collège qui va chercher un
contractuel dans le privé qui n'est pas
forcément un enseignant c'est ta
question j'essaye de concombres comment
ça pourrait se mettre en avant je lui ai
dit oui et ça existe et ça existe déjà
on va typiquement moi je rends un
rapport sur l'insertion des jeunes au
travers du sport dans les quartiers
pardon et dans les quartiers populaires
on va créer des sites et éducatives
olympique où on ouvre effectivement
plutôt d'avoir le sentiment d'avoir
parfois des murs je vous donne un tout
petit exemple très concret on apprend
aujourd'hui vous avez des conseils
d'école et bien sachez que les élus
n'ont pas forcément accès aux conseils
aux conseils d'école de même que l'agent
de la collectivité n'a pas accès aux
conseils d'école on a besoin de
travailler ensemble demain tous ensemble
en faisant tomber les barrières et je
crois que c'est ce qui est propre c'est
par le candidat emmanuel macron à la
fois avec eux avec les élus après à la
fois étaient parents d'élèves à la fois
avec eux avec un certain nombre de
conseils citoyens par exemple à la voilà
il faut rien s'interdire donc plus de
souplesse c'est rigolo
libérales hostiles je mets pas
d'étiquette là dessus je pense le
principal c'est que à la fin des phases
et des élèves puissent étudier dans de
bonnes conditions et surtout un bon
résultat ce n'est pas forcément le cas
quand on voit le bilan des manières
macron parce que vous avez eu raison
beaucoup de candidats table semaine et
mâcon mais parce qu'il est le président
en poste le président sortant et il a un
bilan à défendre et qu'envoient les
classements internationaux quand on voit
le classement pisa oui mais où l'école
forme 13 et 25e on peut se poser
je viens j'ai bien sûr nationale on voit
par exemple aussi la violence qu'on
subit les professeurs c'est aussi un
sujet la façon il en scène par ces
vidéos il ya le matériel il ya là les
financements il ya aussi la façon car
ils peuvent se comporter avec le real va
proposer donc je réagis jamal juste là
dessus et quand on sait qu'il ya 20 ans
49% dans un sondage ifop de gens de
janvier 2021 qui distille
s'autocensurent en cours on peut quand
même réellement s'inquiéter sur la
situation des enseignants dont jeunes
dans le monde est d'accord pour qu'il
gagne plus on sait combien les balises
que vous pourrez poser avec nous on est
un président aussi dense et il semble
qu'ils me semble plein de plaine des
sports et plein d'entrain c'est à dire
que oui si on travaille plus on doit
gagner plus eric zemmour lui veut mettre
en place la prime d'excellence en
notamment en renforçant les inspections
du travail pour les professeurs pour
qu'ils puissent prouver qu'ils ont bien
travaillé et en plus c'est tribunal
permettrait de ne pas rémunérer les
personnes donc à l'ancienneté mais je
suis la preuve
c'est la même logique mais au bon gars
là bien si on en est là on est d'accord
je peux dire que s'il considère que le
travailler plus pour gagner plus c'est
une bonne chose moi je suis d'accord ils
savent qu'il faut taxer moins pour
gagner plus il faut travailler plus pour
gagner plus y compris dans l'éducation
et dans ce cas là aussi d'un registre
national
que dire je suis quand même assez ravi
de vous entendre parce qu'à la base
c'est quand même les profs ce sont les
propositions de valérie pécresse 1 sec
et bien oui c'est bien fou à toi même tu
sais pas qui vous êtes
vous attendiez à ce que je le dise ce
sont les propositions de valérie
pécresse de revaloriser les enseignants
de d'ouvrir d'ouvrir la possibilité de
l'autonomie et du recrutement c'est mais
elle va elle va bien plus loin que ça
moi je vois aussi vous vous dites que
vous êtes en zone prioritaire à saint
denis on nous sommes aussi en zone
prioritaire
les l'école à deux vitesses elle existe
et alors nous on se la prend de plein
fouet il faut savoir qu'un étudiant en
seine-saint-denis un élève en
seine-saint-denis quand ils arrivent au
parcours il fait la totalité de son
parcours il arrive au bac il a perdu
l'équivalent d'un an d'enseignement et
il a perdu l'équivalent d'un an
d'enseignement scolaire parce que il n'y
a pas de remplacement de professeurs
aujourd'hui parce que les moyens ne sont
pas mis et parce que l'école ce ne sont
pas que les enseignants c'est toute
l'équipe c'est toute l'équipe
pédagogique c'est tout l'écosystème qui
permet de faire en sorte qu'un nain
qu'un élève réussissez vous pensez que
le plus de liberté au sein des
établissements dans le recrutement mais
je dans l'évolution des carrières ça va
permettre notamment fait un déluge a
donné des abysses mans qui ce n'est
besoin de renfort rendez vous avez des
étudiants en seconde spécialité histoire
géo au lycée paul eluard des étudiants
en seconde qui n'ont pas eu une heure de
cours d'histoire géo ou qui ont eu très
peu d'heures de cours d'histoire géo
depuis le début de l'année nous sommes
au mois d'avril nous sommes au mois
d'avril vous pensez que les responsables
les responsables des établissements vont
attendre qu'on nomme sagement quelqu'un
pour non ils vont essayer de s'arranger
de prendre des dispositions
les professeurs sont déjà en train de
s'arranger entre eux pour récupérer les
cours et faire les remplacements nous
avons des établissements il manque deux
trois professeurs sur des matières qui
sont très critiques les maths
d'histoire-géo sur des classes qui sont
très critiques la quatrième la seconde
la première à la fin des fins nous le
principal de très gros problèmes qu'on a
en seine-saint-denis sur sur le niveau
le niveau scolaire c'est c'est le non
remplacement des professeurs ça c'est
vraiment la chose qui tape le plus sur
leur côté les élèves celle ci date pas
d'hier
à ce moment là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant cinq ans on va parler de la
revalorisation des enseignants la
revalorisation des enseignants monsieur
blanc caire en avait parlé finalement ça
s'est transformé en prime elle est
passée où elle est passée où cette
réalisation nous mais bien sûr qu'il
vous déprime pour
pour
pour moi il ya le dégel non mais le
dégel du point d'indicé aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'inflation qui est à 3,6
pourquoi aujourd'hui qu'il avait
toujours faut bien s'adapter à l'air du
temps ce n'est pas du tout
2% d'inflation qui passe à 3 6 à 3 26%
ces swaps attendez c'est pas une
trajectoire électoraliste et la télé
réalité du terrain je voudrais aussi
ajouter une chose qui est quand même
important c'est de là je vois d'autres
mesures parce que c'est vraiment un
sujet très important pour nous
l'éducation en seine-saint-denis les
mêmes chances pour tous je le vois à
l'écran je pense nous a tous les élèves
handicapés qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent
pas aller à l'école parce que nous
n'avons pas les ash parce que les ash
n'ont pas déçu elles ne sont pas
rémunérés
calibre dont emmanuel barast
la formation des avs âge on y compris y
compris d'ailleurs sur les activités
périscolaires et c'est très important et
moi j'irais même plus loin j'irai même
plus loin je les formeraient pardon
d'être sur cette thématique la gelée
formeraient même au niveau des sports
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune
élève qui est en situation de handicap
qui est en école primaire il est
accompagné par sont élevées sage donc
son accompagnant en situation de
handicap mais pas forcément ne peut pas
faire de sport parce qu'ils ne sont pas
formés il faut aller sur cette directive
là c'est ce que président c'est ce que
lors de la primaire sont des choses qu'à
droite alors on sent très clairement
cette mesure il est net il ya même à mon
avis déjà des des syndicats qui pour vs
fourbissent leurs armes vous pourrez
fait défiler contre cette mesure
j'imagine tout pas porte oui évidemment
on défilera sur cette mesure mais quand
j'entends ce qui se dit on est
véritablement sur la remise en cause du
statut de fonctionnaire à l'éducation
nationale aujourd'hui on n'a jamais
connu dans la vème république un
président qui dit qu'il va recruter
selon le profil qui va autoriser à
recruter des enseignants selon leur
profil l'école à deux vitesses elle
existe déjà
emmanuel macron veulent accélérer il ya
des sujets on parle notamment de la
question du des profs non remplacés qui
sont véritablement par exemple en scène
sonic l'inquiétude de recrutement il ya
les questions des salaires conditionnée
à d'autres missions mais le non
remplacement des enseignants il doit
être réglé par un recrutement massif
aujourd'hui c'est pas à l'ordre du jour
on veut augmenter les salaires revenant
le point d'applications disant que le
point d'indicé on n'a pas été revalorisé
dans ce pays il ya une colère et il ya
quelques mois une manifestation
historique a eu lieu à paris avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et aujourd'hui on vient leur annoncer
qu'en mai à mort l'école publique dans
ce pays effectivement il y aura des
mobilisations sociales école mise à mort
public s'il fallait lancer un débat à 24
jours sur l'éducation il est sur la
table on va avancer comme ça on va
essayer de comprendre quelles sont les
réactions toujours d'ailleurs dans une
logique un peu de donnant donnant on va
parler du du rsa écoutez
oui il faut un soutien monétaire mais il
faut en plus de ça reconnaître la
dignité de chacun demandé une part
d'efforts pour toutes celles et ceux
qu'ils peuvent et de devoirs et un
accompagnement voilà pas de revenu
minimal sans contrepartie et la
contrepartie voulue par le président
candidat c'est une formation de 15 à 20
heures par semaine ça vous vous assumez
alors j'ai presque envie d'aller voir
tout de suite c'est notamment parce que
c'est la proposition de vale respecter
la vérité expliquez-nous il ya tout à
fait c'est c'est une proposition qu'elle
a mis sur la table très très tôt dans sa
campagne que le rsa puisse être qu'il
puisse y avoir une activité on va dire
professionnels qui puisse être une
contrepartie du rsa et ça ne sort pas de
nulle part il y a eu un rapport de la
cour des comptes en janvier 2022 qui
précise que le rsa dans l'état actuel
dans lequel il est ne remplit pas ses
fonctions de retour à l'emploi et que le
retour à l'emploi l'activité
professionnelle en parallèle du rsa est
essentiel pour en faire un vrai un vrai
moteur de retour à l'emploi et d'une
plage et apolitique a redonné non mais
moi ça me fait doucement sourire je me
demande très honnêtement à vous écouter
je me demande pourquoi valérie pécresse
est si bas dans les sondages non mais
je me demande pourquoi je me suis
emmanuel macron un tel besoin de
récupérer toute la largeur de la dame
pécresse pour pouvoir se faire réélire
je vais juste vous dire moi je suis un
amer qui a été élu en 2014 et le sujet
dont vous parlez j'ai été élu en 2000 en
2015 aux départements le rsa c'est bien
le département qui le met en place futé
est évidemment et j'ai toujours et moi
je suis un chantre de l'art et profite
la réciprocité entre les droits et les
devoirs et donc dans un contrat gagnant
gagnant mais madame pardon mais ça fait
des années qu'on en parle personne ne
l'a mis en place mais assez folle
permettra dès maintenant vous dites je
termine largement qui gère le relais il
ya des départements joie jour est un
gagnant gagnant à l'emploi et ça marche
danse il pas je voudrais juste je vais
juste vous dire rsa revenu de solidarité
active
qu'est ce que c'est le revenu c'est bien
le fruit d'un travail et donc ça me
paraît logique et c'est presque une
mesure de justice et de justesse mais
maintenant était interrogé sur le yacht
est copié collé avec valérie pécresse il
dit moi je ne propose pas comme valérie
pécresse des travaux d'intérêts généraux
les petits jeux sociaux parce que les
bénéficiaires du rsa et et des formes de
détenus
mais ce sujet des formations ou
carrément
monsieur wauquiez diaz ya quelques
années donc c'est une idée de monsieur
wauquiez faire des tiges face au rsa
c'est ubuesque le travail d'intérêt
général c'est une raideur s'il est une
réussite une c'est une mesure une
fiancée tu ne sais pas une punition de
monsieur
elle est aujourd'hui dans son programme
parce qu'elle a fait ses preuves sur les
terrains et elle n'a pas fait ses
preuves sur le terrain en étant des
travaux d'un gène des intérêts généraux
rémunéré par un rsa elle a fait ses
preuves sur le terrain les départements
de droite avec qui nous assure une
véritable il y avait qu une véritable
activité en face du du rsa et du revenu
à l'espace rigaud danse dans cette
question au fond 2 du revenu minimum
avec cette logique derrière on dénonce
beaucoup dans votre camp de l'assistanat
vous ne pouvez qu'être d'accord avec ces
petits écologique du donnant-donnant
cette philosophie et c'est cette
philosophie de donnant d'une zone du
donnant-donnant pardon du concept de
travail plus encore une fois je le dit
chaleur de crédit plus nous on est
évidemment d'accord elle ça mais on
croit rêver cette mesure aussi non non
on n'a pas cette mesure on n'a pas les
trois mêmes programmes sinon on s'en
remettra un peu sur les plateaux mais
nous on n'a pas cette mesure là mais
nous aussi on conserve en ouganda et
xénon on veut mettre en place la prime z
c'est à dire possibilité de faire un
treizième quatorzième à 15 des mois pour
les employeurs qui ne seront ni table
c'est en charge ni à l'impôt ben voilà
nous on veut aussi proposer des choses
comme ça la question du pouvoir d'achat
des travailleurs dans le rsa cible un
peu différent c'est pour ça je vais
accompagnement vers le retour à l'emploi
je vous dis justement c'est que dans
cette logique là on a des mesures qui
vont dans le même sens mais tant mieux
tant mieux si on se rend compte qu'ils
ont à peine d'assister à l'enfance
pardon juste par ailleurs jean apprise
ul de qui a eu l'idée en premier
c'est presque tout faire vieux serpent
de mer je sais pas
à 25 ans mais mais mais mais encore une
fois je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment le coeur coeur du sujet mais
par contre il ya une chose que je
remarque c'est que les deux mais mes
deux compagnons de plateau ce soir on
était aux responsabilités
cependant cinq ans que les maquereaux et
pendant des années des neiges de
responsabilité vous mais encore pardon
jumère effectivement ce de terrain les
soixante ans passés dans la réciprocité
entre les droits et de devoirs que je
verrai ça se passe très bien possible je
ne connais pas je prends même pas d'en
parler pendant j'ai vu le bilan des
macros pendant cinq ans et les
conséquences d'une gestion de la droite
pendant des années et pourquoi tout ça
n'a pas été fait avant sarkozy le pardon
mais le gagner pour travailler plus pour
gagner plus sarkozy en 2007 nous sommes
en 2022 j'ai pas vu beaucoup beaucoup de
changements par rapport à ça donc on
vous assumez sait si on dit que voilà
c'est plutôt un programme de droite n'a
pas de difficulté avec ça j'assume
complètement le fait de dire que c'est
un programme gagnant gagnant où il ya
une réciprocité enfin entre les droits
et les devoirs parfaitement terme
rapporte
conditionnée à 15h15 20h02 de formation
travaille c'est une véritable mesure de
droite et vous avez évoqué dans votre
sujet ce qui était plus à droite
emmanuel macron que en 2017 je crois
qu'il a toujours été à droite et nous on
a toujours considéré comme à droite il
ya une forme de stigmatisation encore de
laisser croire qu'il ya une forme
d'assistanat dans ce pays mais qui peut
croire qu'on ait assisté au rsa quand on
vit avec 565 euros par mois qui peut
croire ça donc on va encore montrer du
doigt une partie de la population en
exigeant des choses et je le disais tout
à l'heure par contre quand on est
beaucoup plus généreux que de l'argent
public à destination des grandes
entreprises là on ne conditionne pas
l'aide donc on voit qu'il ya deux poids
deux mesures mais aussi un véritable
scandale autour du rsa c'est à dire
c'est le non recours aux aides on a
aujourd'hui quasiment 3 milliards
d'euros par an qui sont pas utilisés par
l'état puisqu'ils à des gens qui ne qui
ne font même pas l'europe aux ars à
l'étranger dans un sas de précarité qui
est absolument extrême
chose notre proposition c'est de sortir
ces gens là de la précarité avec ce
qu'on appelle la garantie d'autonomie
qui sera 2063 euros nets par mois et qui
est financée nous l'avons démontré la
semaine dernière présentation chiffrée d
une autre mesure qui
on peut dire marche un peu avec ce
nouveau rsa c'est la fusion des toutes
les aides sociales alors ils appellent
ça des minima les minima sociaux à la
source la solidarité à la source ce qui
permettrait en fait de limiter thème non
recours aux aides ok ça va exactement
dans le social les personnes en droit et
puis de lutter contre contre la fraude
la fraude sociale un million de foyers
concernés sur sur le sujet de la même
manière qu'eux il ya eu quelque chose
d'inédit qui a été fait dans ce dans ce
quinquennat c'est le prélèvement à la
source où tout le monde disait ça sera
jamais possible ont été les derniers de
l'europe à le faire aujourd'hui cette
idée effectivement de mutualiser
l'ensemble des aides soudain forme d'un
espèce de revenu universel date
d'activité va dans le bon sens parce que
y aura pas besoin comme vous le dit à
juste titre d'aller taper à des portes
où on pourrait avoir effectivement à ses
indemnités parfois on le sait on le sait
même pas et il faut absolument les
demandes et là il y aura plus à les
demander puisqu'elles seront lissés avec
ce ce versement de solidarité beaucoup
de choses hein on va pas tout à gré
n'est la retraite à 65 ans on a déjà
débattu de ce sujet sur ce plateau vous
rejoignez la borne d'âge de valérie
pécresse ya beaucoup d'investissements
aussi en matière de santé à l'hôpital
également la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux au total ces 50 milliards
d'euros par an le coût global de ce de
ce projet macron si l'on peut dire
qu'ils financent notamment par le retour
de la croissance 20 milliards de la
simplification 15 milliards et 15 autres
milliards et là c'est plus flou très
clairement par des réductions de coûts
sur les collectivités publiques alors il
le dit pas clairement mais il y aura des
suppressions de postes de fonctionnaires
oui ou non et lesquelles alors non et de
le président ne nommer le président ne
dis pas ça par exemple il revient sur
l'accord sur quelque chose dont on parle
depuis une vingtaine d'années et que
edouard philippe lorsqu'il était premier
ministre avait évoqué le conseiller
territorial monsieur le disait nicolas
sarkozy elle avait également imaginé le
conseiller territorial permet aussi de
mutualiser les coûts je vous donne un
exemple suprême de fête voilà ses
actionnaires pour un seul un certain
nombre d'élus au passerait de six mille
élus aujourd'hui à
4000 ou 4000 à 4500 c'est là que vous
trouvez
je dis juste que c'est passé il ya des
outils et il faut prendre les outils les
uns avec avec les autres mets
typiquement pendant l'épidémie c'était
quand même étonnant de voir que le matin
nous avions un conseiller départemental
qu'elle est distribué des masques dans
les collèges et que l'après midi on
avait un conseil régional qu'elle est
distribué les mêmes masque dans des
lycées c'est bien un moment donné aussi
des peut-être d'ajuster de mutualiser
finalement d'être pragmatique et de bon
sens alors j'ai terminé ce débat par une
question simple avoue 3 puisque vous
avez d'en parler car le livre qu'est ce
qui vous distingue par rapport à ce
projet très complet qui a été présentée
on n'a pas parlé du régalien mais il en
a dit quelques mots sur le pacte
républicain s'il ya vraiment une ligne
de fracture qui permet de distinguer
chacun des candidats que vous devez vous
défendez stanislas rigaux sl je n'aurais
pas parlé mais moi je dirais que c'est
sûr évidemment les sujets mots qui me
économie on a vu des attentions pardon
une
vingtaine de petites minutes évident
mais c'est les jeux de la télévision
évidemment qui une philosophie commune à
certains moments précis sur le travail
et gagner plus le travailler plus pour
gagner plus c'est une chose encore une
fois ça si c'est juste une question de
philosophie politique à la rigueur sur
tel ou tel aspect pourquoi pas l'antenne
sur le régalien en moi j'ai pas tout
compris lorsque croisé mâle macro ya
parlé notamment choix de de fonction
publique pour la sécurité rajouter ça
mais j'ai pas bien compris que c'était
peut-être qu'il va là ils valent
explicité dans les jours à venir mais
encore une fois sur l'immigration moi je
ne sens pas de grands changements à
venir ne sont pas de prise de conscience
sur ses larmes de l'asile pour
expulser les voies destin mais pardon il
aurait dû faire pendant cinq ans donc
voila moi j'ai pas senti de grands
changements là dessus et puis surtout
moi et même ma tronche des sorties
encore une fois dans le même temps moi
je vendais exemple très simple il nous
dit y voir un adjectif très fort puis
dans le même temps à parlement très fort
enfin c'est encore une fois le en même
temps parfait et d'ailleurs sur ce
plateau s'étaient illustrés ou en fait
monsieur était d'accord et avec monsieur
portes et avec des élus je précise et il
vous est donc voila moi sur le régalien
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais ce sera
l'inde est l'une des grosses faiblesses
dans les 25 joueurs bas partent avec
jean luc mélenchon la distinction
fondamentale avec ce programme présenté
aujourd'hui est celle notre programme
l'avenir en commun c'est résumé c'est
c'est une vision sociale et écologique
de la société qui priorise l'intérêt
général sur les intérêts privés vous
avez évoqué une question qui est un
marqueur fondamental pour nous c'est la
question des retraites où nous on dit la
retraite à 60 ans pour tous avec 40
annuités avec 1400 euros net par mois
c'est la question de la planification
écologique d'heure le présente d
emmanuel macron a repris ce terme de
planification donc ça veut dire que dans
la bataille des idées on est aussi en
train d'avancer et c'est enfin la
préservation de la planète et des enjeux
environnementaux
je rappelle que ce président de la
république a été condamné quand même
deux fois pour une action climatique et
si on met encore une fois c'est une
grande de plus d' emmanuel macron ça va
être terrible pour les plus fragiles
même question et je suis sûr que ceux
qui nous regardent sont attentifs à
votre réponse parce que qu'est-ce qui
vous distingue fondamentalement dans le
camp pécresse de ce programme la clarté
de la vision de là où est-ce qu'on veut
aller aujourd'hui ce qu'on a vu et
d'ailleurs tous vos collègues
journalistes un la plupart ont twitté et
on était d'accord avec ça c'est un
président candidat a faim c'est un
candidat qui a repris l'essentiel de
d'un programme qu'on défend depuis des
mois à droite vous êtes l'original ils
sont la copie
il y a des choses il y a des choses qui
qui qui qui sont là et qui font sens
c'est à dire que ce sont des choses dont
on parle depuis très longtemps et qui
doivent être mises en place aujourd'hui
effectivement qui qui sont logiques mais
la manière dont le programme est
architecturé la vision que le programme
porte parler du régalien parler de
parler de la dette on à 2800 milliards
d'euros de dettes aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'ils proposent pour par rapport à ces
par rapport à cette dette monstrueuse
qui arrivent et qui seront qui sera le
mur de des impôts de demain il ya un
mois je ne vois pas où est ce qu il veut
aller ce que je vois c'est que c'est un
candidat de contrefaçon hippiques un
bout à gauche un coup à droite il fait
son programme il a su et vous seuls
protagonistes à droite mais derrière on
peut se poser une vraie question de
vision la chose aussi le point - de
rupture je trouve aussi avec le
programme des manuels macron c'est le
pouvoir d'achat
d'un mot pour conclure un pardon d'un
mot pour conclure parce que le débat
s'achève sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est
que ce qui pourra apporter enfin ce qui
pose sera une vraie marge de manoeuvre
pour le pouvoir d'achat demain pour les
français c'est d'avoir une vraie
réflexion sur la fiscalité sur les taxes
et sur voilà sur le coût de la vie qui
aujourd'hui est en train d'exploser on
ne peut pas - je ne crois pas une
politique de chèques permanent trois
mois quatre mois par ci pour compenser
une augmentation du gasoil pour
augmenter pour compenser une
augmentation de l'alimentation il faut
avoir une règlement il faut avoir une
réflexion de fond et aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas cette réflexion de fond pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français et je suis
dans un département qui est
particulièrement pauvre est concerné par
le pouvoir d'achat alors jeu honnêtement
je ne suis pas convaincu alors on a
beaucoup parlé du pouvoir d'achat on est
dans une période d'inflation que la
guerre est dans du cred a des
conséquences très importantes sur mais
vous pouvez dire un mot mais vraiment en
10 15 secondes parce qu'on a déjà
dépassé alors trés bien vivement le
président adossé à un bilan avec un taux
de chômage au plus bas quasiment
historique y compris chez les jeunes on
va aller vers le premier le le plein
emploi au cours de ces de ces cinq ans
avait l'emploi c'est notre premier
combat au quotidien nous autres les
maires et ça d'être le premier combat
pour notre beau pays après évidemment
qu'on est dans le grand dépassements et
que des idées qu'elles soient de gauche
ou caniveaux de droite celle soient
efficaces et qu'elles sont bonnes pour
la france c'est la france qui gagne
c'est la france qui rassemble merci
beaucoup d'être venus débattre à chaud
de ce don de ce projet maintenant voilà
on va le déplier y aura d'autres
d'autres débats c'est sûr sur les
différents thèmes les différentes
propositions dévoilées par le
président-candidat aujourd'hui merci à
vous on va à présent accueillir une
figure de la médecine humanitaire il est
médecin de guerre il a formé des
médecins syrien sur le terrain depuis
l'invasion de l'ukraine il alerte à la
fois sur la stratégie de terreur de
vladimir poutine la même qu'en syrie et
sur le risque aussi de voir le crem se
vider de sa population raphaël pitié
dans ça vous regarde ce soir on a plein
de questions à lui poser comme les skis
ce sujet des deux mondes un gars va
regarder
si on vous invite ce soir raphaël pythie
c'est parce que selon vous l'histoire se
répète
l'ukraine aujourd'hui vous fait penser à
la syrie d'hier la syrie le combat de
votre vie raphaël pythie vous êtes
médecin militaire anesthésistes
réanimateurs
formateur de soignants vous avez exercé
au bout du monde comme au coin de votre
rue dans l'armée à nancy metz ou encore
en syrie dès 2016 vous pointiez déjà la
responsabilité du régime russe dans le
massacre des syriens quand on voit ces
enfants qui arrivent ces familles qui
sont détruites c'est sous la volonté
russe quand même que cela se fait et
sous l'égide des russes que cela se fait
donc il ya un cynisme on ne peut pas
dire que moralement d'accord on peut
s'appuyer sur poutine qui est d'un
cynisme terrible aujourd'hui vous fait
le parallèle entre les deux pays
notamment sur la question des réfugiés
un débat qui s'est invitée dans la
campagne présidentielle française
il y a ceux pour qui les réfugiés
ukrainiens sont avant tout des réfugiés
et ne pas trier des exilés des familles
qui suit la guerre les êtres humains ne
se trient pas en fonction de leur
couleur ou de leur religion et les
autres pour qu'ils sont avant tout des
ukrainiens les ukrainiens sont de vrais
réfugiés qui fuient la guerre parce que
nous nous sentons proches d'eux parce
qu'ils sont européens parce qu'ils sont
chrétiens
pour vous raphaël pitt il faut
évidemment les accueillir bien sûr mais
attention à ne pas tomber dans le piège
de vladimir tout dans les médias on est
dans cet élan de solidarité était très
important et après on va se confronter
un véritable problème qui est la prise
en charge de ces millions de personnes
et j'ai tout à craindre de penser quand
on regarde ce qui s'est passé en syrie
que l'on va que poutine pas
instrumentaliser ce les réfugiés c'est à
dire les pousser à partir alors syrie
ukraine même destin tragique
comment instaurer des zones de
désescalade de la violence peut-on
gagner la guerre sans la faire
la solidarité des français vis-à-vis des
réfugiés ukrainien aura-t-elle des
limites à moins d'un mois de l'élection
présidentielle vous interpeller les
candidats avec un seul objectif raphaël
pythie que l'histoire ne se répète pas
bonsoir raphaël pittsburgh c'est un
grand plaisir de vous recevoir sur ce
plateau la guerre est entrée dans sa
troisième semaine il admire poutine
poursuit sa stratégie de terreur et la
siège les villes à bombarder civils y
avaient l'hôpital pour enfants de mario
paul à marioupol aujourd'hui le théâtre
qui a été bombardé alors on a peu
d'informations il ya il y avait un un
abri dans lequel plusieurs centaines de
personnes s'étaient réfugiées
apparemment il aurait tenu mais il faut
être prudent avec ces informations et
ces images elles soient insupportables
comment vous qui avait alerté depuis
tant d'années qui connaissait l'horreur
de la guerre de près sur le terrain vous
vivez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
ukraine et bien c'est un véritable
déchirement parce que c'est une histoire
qui se renouvelle de nouveau cette
souffrance des ukrainiens si celle des
syriens martyrisé depuis dix ans les
bombardements systématiques la
destruction des hôpitaux la destruction
des écoles des sanctions des
boulangeries au point que les syriens se
lever la nuit pour aller chercher le
pain vous avez vu cette boulangerie de
l'accueil où ces gens qui faisait la
queue ont été tuées et donc tout cela
les céréales ont vécu pendant dix ans et
personnes en tenue de l'unomin
population pourquoi alors que
effectivement vous vous aviez alerté à
de nombreuses reprises il ya une forme
de signature dans ces bombardements
signature jean alep la gutta sommes
aussi pourquoi n'at-on jamais tiré des
leçons de la syrie écoutez il n'y a pas
de la part des occidentaux ont tous des
cas de la diplomatie internationale il
n'y a pas de vraie volonté politique de
s'affronter à poutine et donc qui est
extrêmement déterminé extrêmement
déterminé et il s'est en même temps
qu'il peut justement cette
d'éternuements sa détermination d'autant
plus forte qu'il sait que face à lui il
y a des gens au ventre mou c'est à dire
qu'ils condamnent en permanence qui
évoque effectivement ces crimes contre
l'humanité qui cherche éventuellement
mettre en place a remplacé dès la
politique par de l'humanitaire
considérant que comme ça ça les lave au
même temps de leur incapacité élèves de
3e de la lâcheté dans la sht et
proposent fruits de la lâcheté parce que
nous sommes tellement attaché et
éventuellement à nos intérêts propres
dans ce monde purement individualiste
que nous voulons bien soutenir à
condition que ça ne met pas en jeu notre
mode de vie regardez aujourd'hui les
allemands par exemple qu'il se refuse à
ne plus acheter de pétrole ou de gaz
mais ça me choque c'est choquant
profondément
il regarde la guerre non n'est pas prêt
à se priver at il un peu exactement
exactement exactement nous sommes dans
cette situation là nous sommes dans une
situation nous voulons soutenir bien sûr
mais la solidarité elle est à condition
de ne pas prendre de risque pour moi
même avant qu'elle ait un engagement
sans risque int l'engagement n'existe
pas sans risque donc vous vous appelez
au fond un embargo européen sur le gaz
et de pétrole n'est pas forcément une
intervention militaire à une
intervention militaire la violence ne
doit pas se rajouter à la violence bien
évidemment ou alors nous considérons que
poutine a gagné et ça sert à rien de
gesticuler et faire souffrir le peuple
ukrainien comme le peuple syrien depuis
dix ans alors si c'est comme ça
négociant directement maintenant des
coûts type laissons-lui le d'en-bas sait
ce qu'il veut et acceptons là et qu'il
est prêt à négocier si on veut bien être
tout
il voudra certainement la neutralité de
l'ukraine bien évidemment et il voudra
éventuellement récupérer le dombass à ce
moment là ce sera peut-être suffisant
pour lui compte tenu de cette situation
parce qu'il est dans une station
militaire un peu difficile il aussi sur
le plan économique il n'a pas envie de
poursuivre juste de subir des sanctions
qui sont là donc il peut peut-être
négocier si on d'emblée on accepte c'est
sa volonté est tombé en six mois
nouvelle fois combien de temps à votre
très très longtemps alors il voudra
certainement montré par mario paul en
particulier va être une ville martyre
mais qui sera en maintenant un exemple
pour les autres villes et donc à mario
khadir et c'est à dire qu'il va montrer
à marioupol sa détermination il détruira
comme il a détruit à l'aide comme il a
détruit la gutta d'une manière
systématique tout ce qui est pour
douaniers à terroriser la population à
l'enfermer dans ces abris sans qu'elle
puisse avoir ni chauffage ni électricité
ni ravitaillement il détruira les
hôpitaux bien évidemment ils pourront
pas se soigner et il attendra
tranquillement en faisant cela jusqu'à
ce qu'il finisse par céder en fait il
veut vider quelque part ces villes il
voir population ni volontairement oui il
ne veut pas l'affrontement il a bien
tiré il a bien tiré les leçons de
l'afghanistan pendant l'enlisement qui
l'ont eu en afghanistan dont il n'est
pas du tout à la recherche d'une
confrontation face à face une armée
contre une autre arme et il ne veut pas
rentrer dans une ville et à ce moment là
être dans une situation de combat de rue
et qui sont extrêmement
très risqué pour ces hommes et ces dons
qu'il l'a cette stratégie qui est
encerclé et bombardé à siéger jusqu'à ce
que la population cède on va s'arrêter
un instant sur la question des réfugiés
raphaël pidoux parce que votre discours
sur réfugiés y bouscule surtout venant
d'un d'un humanitaire près de 3 millions
d'ukrainiens ont fui le pays la france
organise pour en accueillir cent mille
clément perreault s'est rendu à la
frontière polonaise principales portes
d'entrée de toutes ces familles d'exil
et regardez ce reportage
[Musique]
nous sommes à la frontière entre la
pologne et l'ukraine
chaque jour ici des centaines de
réfugiés affluent ce sont
essentiellement des femmes des enfants
et des personnes âgées ils arrivent
épuisés par leur voyage et traumatisés
par les combats dans leur pays
alina vient de se reposer quelques
minutes dans cette tente elle reprend la
route avec sa fille à ses côtés
c'était très long nous sommes arrivés en
trains
le voyage a duré environ 16 heures
mais maintenant je me sens en sécurité
avec ma fille nous sommes tous très
inquiets pour le cren et nos proches qui
sont restés
et que ce que vous attendez maintenant
de l'europe un ne demandons que soit
fermé l'espace aérien de l'ukraine s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
nous attendons vraiment ça
parce que si vous ne le faites pas je
pense que la russie va détruire toute
l'ukraine par le ciel
[Musique]
à 400 km de là la gare centrale de
varsovie
elle a depuis plusieurs jours des
allures de camp de réfugiés il attend
ici de trouver des structures capables
de les accueillir en pologne où ailleurs
en europe beaucoup dorment à même le sol
les enfants sont très nombreux
irena vient d'arriver avec ses deux fils
elle est en ligne avec sa mère restée en
ukraine
elle pleure c'est maman
elle est très inquiète pour nous et
surtout pour les enfants
et où est leur père il est resté pour
combattre oui il est resté à la maison
je voulais rester aussi mais j'étais
obligé de partir à cause des enfants
à la gare de varsovie comme à la
frontière des bénévoles de l'europe
entière sont mobilisés pour accueillir
ces réfugiés le gouvernement polonais de
son côté redoutent que l'afflux ne
deviennent trop importants dans les
prochains jours il met la pression pour
que l'europe le soutiennent au maximum
raphaël petit le commissaire européen à
l'aide humanitaire estime à 7 millions
le nombre de déplacés à venir ça va être
la plus grande crise humanitaire que
l'europe a connu depuis depuis des
années des décennies notamment depuis la
dernière guerre mondiale quand il dit à
us justement après l'occupation par les
russes de toute la partie est de
l'europe il ya eu cette fuite et en
particulier de l'allemagne de l'est il
ya eu cette fille très importante vers
l'ouest pour fuir bien sûr les russes à
ce moment là et donc on va être devant
dans la même situation dont vous
entendez dire dans le sujet attention
attention c'est pas forcément une bonne
chose que que ces familles fuient en
masse parce que c'est au fond ce que
souhaite l'admirent potel bien sûr il va
les instrumentaliser vers nous en
particulier nous mettre devant cette
situation qui est de prendre en charge
peut être vite à 10 millions de
personnes et ça va poser véritablement
sur le plan social sur le plan humain ça
va poser de véritables problèmes vous
allez voir montée des populismes
maintenant offerts ne pas les accueillir
non bien évidemment il faut bien pour
ceux qui sont là dès à présent il faut
envisager justement la prise en charge
de ces populations elles sont
complètement sidérée elles ont perdu
tous leurs repères même temps ils n'ont
pas d'avenir et il suffit de se rendre
compte j'étais à la frontière bien
évidemment et il faut se rendre compte
du calme et du silence dans laquelle
cela se passe d'ailleurs vos images le
montrent aussi ces populations sont
totalement sidéré il n'y a aucune colère
il n'y a qu'un il ya une espèce
d'attentes
donc en même temps il faudrait aussi
trouver une solution pour qu'elle ne
s'éloigne pas trop de l'ukraine pour
même qu'elle puisse rester dans des
élans des négociations du floridor
humanitaire il faut obtenir ce que
erdogan avait réussi à obtenir du
conseil de sécurité c'est-à-dire zone de
désescalade de la violence à l'intérieur
même de l'ukraine et qu'il y ait un
ravitaillement possible avec les ong
puissent rentrer dans ces zones de
désescalade pour prendre en charge la
population ukrainienne à l'intérieur du
crâne mon mba les noms et nous l'avons
fait pourtant pour en syrie où il ya eu
quatre zones de désescalade non survol
aérien de ces de ses hommes forts les
terres et touahri sur des territoires
sérieux avec 4,4 corridor humanitaire
nehar question rafale pythie vous
interpeller les candidats à la
présidentielle on les a entendus eric
zemmour très clairement distinguée trier
entre les bons et les mauvais réfugiés
très clairement c'est scandaleux
scandaleux mais c'est scandaleux même
but même vis-à-vis de la manière dont
nous accueillons aujourd'hui les
ukrainiens quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé en 2015-2016 la manière dont nous
avons accueilli les réfugiés syriens qui
sont arrivés la manière dont nous nous
sommes comportés s'il n'y avait pas eu
madame merkel pour prendre les 800000
l'europe aurait complètement explosé
parce que les gens n'ont vous n'est pas
parce qu'ils étaient musulmans parce
qu'ils venaient des pays du moyen orient
et c'est là nous considérons que se sont
ils nous sont proches par le voisinage
par la culture par deux poids deux
mesures qu'ils ratent deux poids deux
mesures qu'est ce que vous attendez des
candidats qu'est ce que vous leur dites
ce soir et surtout alors une chose qui a
été fait pendant ces dix années
c'est-à-dire leur incapacité à trouver
des solutions politiques de renforcer
leur détermination
de faire en sorte que la justice le
droit humanitaire international soient
respectés là au plus haut point moi je
ne supporte plus ces hommes politiques
qui remplace l'action humanitaire en
pensant que ça justifie que cela l'ait
en quelque sorte vis-à-vis de leur
incapacité à trouver des solutions
politiques le remplace par l'humanité
l'humanitaire et à nous
mettre bien évidemment de trouver des
solutions politiques merci beaucoup
merci merci pour cette analyse votre
témoignage raphaël puis vous allez
rester avec quoi on va voilà allez dans
un sujet plus léger en ouvrant la page
présidentielle de de cette émission ça
s'appelle le scan on est à 24 jours du
premier tour regarder
[Musique]
mais avant d'être il y a les deux bras
de fatalité au grand remplacement et
bien moi je vous propose le round mort
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
vous exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur d'arriver à cela pas de mystère
c'est le vol
et nos trois chroniqueurs nous ont
rejoints ce soir stéphane comme tous les
soirs le carnet de campagne dans un
instant benjamin grange les réseaux
sociaux président de mascara et richard
wehrli bonsoir richard bonsoy meriane
france contre elle-même c'est son
nouveau livre lisez le c'est une
démarche absolument original est
totalement dans l'air du temps vous avez
suivi cette ligne de démarcation de 1940
qui a fracturé la france en deux et vous
avez rencontré des français c'est une
réflexion c'est aussi à reporter on en
verra peut-être quelques mots comment
savait que vous plaisir stéphane l'oeil
de blacko ce soir a été attirée par qui
et par quoi et bien sachant
qu'aujourd'hui tous les yeux seront
rivés vers le président plutôt le
candidat macron je me suis dit je vais
regarder ailleurs et donc j'ai regardé
mon télé 7 jours figurent une prière
soir il y avait chez hanouna marine le
pen je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller au
regard d'une bière des chips on y va on
n'a pas trop marché d'ailleurs à cette
émission alors quand même date à la plus
conne s'adressait 1 million 400 mille
personnes ce qui est quand même sacré
mythix est offert mais ce qui donne
cette impression c'est que quand
mélenchon est passé dans l'émission
presse avant il avait fait un million
huit cent mille personnes et or they
moore lui avait clairement fait deux
millions deux cent mille le record la
première fois donc c'est moins bien donc
mauvaise soirée ou pas vraiment super
bonne soirée avant la ville et la map
pour marine le pen en tout cas parce que
je savais que les émissions de canal
sont essentiellement regardé par les
jeunes et les classes populaires et
alors ça tombe bien parce que
l'électorat de marine le pen ce sont les
jeunes et les classes populaires dont
vous faites quand elle est chez nous la
marine le pen est un peu chez elle voyez
on a fait un sondage pour savoir quelles
étaient les le vote des fans donc
hanouna et on voit que y votent
majoritairement pour marine le pen
portrait robot du fan fou d'allah est en
crise et il ya ce problème c'est
l'abstention hier alors avant de ranger
du vote et l'essayer au moins ça
marchait ou pas est ce que ça donnait
envie de voter pour elle alors écoutez
ça fait quand même quelques années que
ma part tient plus à la jeunesse ni
vraiment aux classes populaires vont
suis pas tout à fait la cible de marine
le pen bellemare quand même impressionné
un petit résumé ouais si vous voulez
comment elle a progressé en fait je
voulais dire par rapport à 2010 est bon
elle est confrontée à jean messia qui
est donc quelqu'un qui a quitté le
rassemblement national pour rejoindre
eric zemmour est donc ce monsieur mais
c'est leur reprocher ce mini zemmour lui
reprocher en fait d'avoir posé en fait
qu'un selphy auprès d'une jeune fille
voilée et donc elle a dû se défendre par
contraste elle apparaissait modéré
humaine engagé mais vous allez voir que
elle défend une jeune fille voilée c'est
inattendu
je vais te faire comprendre la
différence entre lutter contre
l'islamisme et s'attaquer à des jeunes
filles qui devaient pas avoir plus de 15
ans et qui voulait faire une photo avec
moi qu'est ce que tu aurais fais toi
sinon c'est son voile
j'en ai pas cuit alors on l'avait déjà
vu comme ça défendre des rues dévoilé il
sait pas tout vous savez comment aussi
un point faible de manque de sérieux par
phare de son projet notamment sur le
plan économique et donc là elle a voulu
marquer des points par rapport à zemmour
à 10 ans ce projet d amour c'est
beaucoup de mots mais c'est pas sérieux
on écoute
parce que moi je suis allé voir le
programme d'eric zemmour sur l'islam
honnêtement ces piteux il ya six petits
points ça fait un quart de page sur 70
pages du programme donc je me dis faire
de l'islam le coeur de son projet
politique pour sortir un truc comme ça
alors je dis c'est pas sérieux vous nous
on a travaillé gens nous on n'a pas fait
ça d'accord on a fait un vrai travail un
travail sérieux et un travail sérieux
c'est autre chose vois tu tu vois on a
fait un projet de loi à référendum sur
l'immigration voilà le référendum sur
l'immigration c'est un projet de loi il
est rédigé où est le vôtre ces
transitions tutoiement bonne leçon de
câbles crédibilité de sérieux qu elle s
est donné à 20
qu'en 2017 alors plus critique en 2007
c'est quand même pas dit ici là on se
souvient tous comment macron la
plaignante deux secondes dès le début du
débat d'ailleurs on l'a sans doute voulu
le rappeler des mauvais souvenirs hier
l'homme est en face à un jeune banquier
encore un jeune banquier alors elle
devait expliquer son programme
économique et donc on sent la passion
qu'elle a fait des progrès dans au
départ en tout cas elle fait des progrès
après vous avoir c'est un peu plus
laborieux on écoute et je mets en place
1 comment dire une relance keynésienne
sur fonds privés par l'intermédiaire du
fonds souverain que je vais mettre en
oeuvre qui va permettre au français de
devenir actionnaires en fait de la
maison france qui est quand même dont
j'espère que îlots il atteindra 500
milliards à la fin du quinquennat alors
bon donc en fait ce fonds souverains
j'espère que elle expliquera mieux à
macron savoir s'économiser font plutôt
vente qu'il a plutôt été bénéficiaire
pour elle on l'a même rang bord du
sympathique regarder hanouna qui montre
ses talents au karaoké je le chante oui
je sais ça je le savais je chante très
bien elle a chanté dalida
s'est fait une petite petite compilation
de vos prestations que j'écoute très
souvent dans la voiture
regardez
des mots toujours des mots
les mêmes mots
ah oui j'ai découvert une autre sans
marine le pen était à peu près plus
modérée paraît plus sérieuse elle paraît
plus détendu et donc moi je la vois bien
second tour et j'irai au dessus des 20
au premier tour bon bah écoutez c'est
écrit un bon jour on pourra parler des
risques la marque audi continue à parler
de la campagne avec vous c'est vrai
qu'on se disait voilà cette campagne
elle peine à décoller écrasé par par ce
retour du tragique dans l'histoire la
guerre en ukraine sur les réseaux
sociaux n'en parle de plus en plus ou
pas attention aux apparences vous donnez
de ce soir oui la campagne
présidentielle on en parle de plus en
plus sur les réseaux sociaux mais mais
les apparences sont parfois bien
trompeuses et finalement la courbe parle
d'elle même si on la voit à l'écran
entre décembre et maintenant on a
presque quatre fois plus de
conversations qui parle des candidats
vous allez me dire c'est un peu normal
puisque la campagne a commencé mais on
est capable de dater un peu les choses
on va trouver et on le voit bien lier
sur la courbe duo un premier pic vers le
10 janvier quel est le moment le moment
finalement où le président non encore
candidat vous voulez je cite emmerder
les français et ça ça a beaucoup fait
parler et puis il ya eu un deuxième pic
de 27 février
là on reparle en fait du président c'est
là où il est allé négocier avec la
dignité poutine en russie et en d'autres
termes cette courbe et les conversations
sont pratiquement à 30% alimenté non pas
par les candidats mais par un candidat
en particulier qui est le président de
la république et si on en enlève cette
courbe là et d'ailleurs on peut la
revoir à l'écran c'est on tombe sur la
courbe du bas et là on voit bien que
c'est beaucoup plus plat que c'est un
gros coup moins ça a beaucoup moins
d'intérêt après quand on en parle de
quoi parlent les différents internautes
c'est assez simple il parle à peu près
toujours de la même chose l'inflation
alors il en parle pas de cette manière
là mais tous les exos toutes les
conséquences de l'inflation évidemment
le pouvoir d'achat avec eux avec les
sens et encore le code locaux vides bref
les problèmes du quotidien qui sont pas
forcément ceux dont on parle
véritablement dans la campagne et deux
émissions qui poussent aux commentaires
sur les réseaux sociaux oui alors y en a
une on en a déjà vous parlez c'est le
fameux face à baba de cyril hanouna et
voilà voilà et là on voit on voit encore
des coupes qui parle d'elle-même je vois
pas ce que vous regardez ça sympa c'est
hanouna et finalement quand on regarde
la courbe c'est la petite courbe et qui
est tout en bas des mentions en fait de
la manière dont de l'ensemble des
internautes vont parler suite à cette à
cette émission et finalement il en parle
pas beaucoup et en revanche on assure la
courbe du haut une émission qui dont on
parle beaucoup qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit et qui a finalement eu un vrai
impact sur la campagne c'était fin avec
face à la guerre et face à la guerre
pourquoi en plus que le débat mâcon à
zemmour à peu près à parts dans un fois
plus utile aux mille fois plus quand on
regarde tout cas pas à peu près 10 fois
plus et pourquoi finalement c'est à
m'assurer des gens et pourquoi cette
émission est là elle a vraiment marché
simplement parce que au delà de parler
de de la guerre on a surtout parlé du
quotidien et de l'impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat et c'est le thème principal qui
intéresse aujourd'hui des français merci
et benjamin merci voilà une forme de
caisse de résonance à ne pas des
sondages mais ça permet de prendre la
température notamment quand on dit que
cette campagne de peine à décoller alors
on va parler des écolos avec vous
richard les écologistes avère boulevard
et on voit bien que malgré le fait que
ce soit une grande priorité pour les
français ne décolle pas pour quelles
raisons selon vous alors effectivement
il y à une énigme quand même dans cette
campagne c'est l'énigme yannick jadot
puisque les sondages lui donnent à peu
près 6 % des voix au début il était
plutôt proche des 10 et on se disait que
porté par les élections européennes de
2019 vous vous souvenez 13,5 pour cent
il avait le boulevard dont vous parlez
notamment en raison des préoccupations
climatiques écologiques etc or il se
retrouve au niveau de celui qu'il avait
rallié en 2017 c'est à dire benoît hamon
pas besoin de vous faire un tableau
c'était quand même à l'époque perçu
comme un échec absolu silas il a réussi
à atteindre 6% yannick jadot sera le
meilleur score d'un candidat écologiste
à la présidentielle mais franchement on
en attendait mieux alors je me suis
interrogé pourquoi est il y a à mon sens
deux raisons la première c'est que le
parti de yannick jadot les verts n'est
peut-être pas un parti qui aux yeux des
français apparaît comme un parti de
gouvernement pourtant d'autres pays
européens c'est précisément ce que les
verts safer on pense à l'allemagne en
attendant la coalition pourquoi en
france il n'y arrive pas parce qu'il ya
cette image contestataires qui leur
colle à la peau c'est au fond un parti
de la contestation permanente alors on
envoie des eurodéputés à bruxelles parce
que là ça ne mange pas de pain mais par
contre les avants dans un gouvernement
on n'a peut-être de la peine à concevoir
un ruisseau un peu il y aller fait
effectivement se sont un peu entraîné
aussi par l'effondrement de lagos mais
il y a une deuxième énigme c'est
pourquoi le succès aux municipales qui
était quand même assez important avec
des grandes villes qui sont passés dans
le giron écologistes à commencer par
lyon pourquoi ça ne se traduit pas dans
les faits et là moi je pose la question
alors à nos amis qui jurait les réseaux
sociaux des jeunes on pourrait penser
que les jeunes auraient rallié en masse
yannick jadot et ça ne semble pas être
le cas puisque les jeunes aujourd'hui
semble davantage tentés par l'abstention
doc au fond voilà l'énigme jadot la
réponse à cette énigme c'est que d'une
part on le perçoit pas comme
présidentiable et on ne perçoit pas son
parti comme vraiment une force
gouvernementale et surtout il a
peut-être racheter raté le coche de la
jeunesse en voulant se technicisé en
parlant de sujets comme le nucléaire et
c'est peut-être qu'il aurait dû d'abord
quatrième concéderait d'un mot c'est
plié pour personne c'est plié pour
personne sûrement pas par lui mais il
est à la peine quand même puisque les
sondages ils sont plats il n'y a pas de
n'y a pas de hausse en deux mots la
france contre elle-même racontez nous en
deux mots parce que c'est l'idée d'aller
sur la ligne de démarcation de 1940 pour
une raison simple c'est qu'à l'époque où
je me suis mis sur ce livre tout le
monde parlait de la disparition de la
france où l'instigation des risées mots
vous savez si on était hanté par la
disparition de la france est bien en
1940 c'est le moment où la france aurait
dû disparaître s'il ya un moment dans
l'histoire récente où elle aurait dû
disparaître ces 1904 vous et trois du
g20 avait rencontré contre laquelle
vivent absolument chaque côté de cette
ligne à un moment où voilà dans cette
guerre n'aura même à nice l imaginaire
mentale village où il ya eu il y a eu
durant cette période évidemment un
contingent de absolue mais ça
c'est le lot de tous les pays par contre
la france elle a continué d'exister elle
a résisté même à cette époque là ça
prouve que lé résilience de la
démarcation de 40 aux fractures
d'aujourd'hui c'est chez gras fait
sécher c'est signé richard vient d merci
infiniment rafale pitié de nous avoir
accompagnés durant cette émission merci
à vous les scanner et à très vite très
belle soirée sur lcp à demain
[Musique]